voilà Léa tu es stressé un petit peu ou
pas encore ça va peut-être venir je suis
pas trop stressé je suis plus dans le
l'écriture des questions avec les Salamé
l'ordre c'est d'anticiper prendre
possession des lieux se sentir se sentir
bien à l'aise dans un studio que je ne
connais pas un plateau qui est pas le
plateau habituel
[Musique]
des exploits de grands défis il y a des
gens qui nous regardent et qui
voudraient eux aussi aller au bout de
même qu'est-ce qu'on leur donne comme
conseil je pense que le conseil c'est
tout simplement de se lancer des
objectifs quotidiennement et réalisables
pour prendre petit à petit confiance en
soi moi je me suis pas lancé comme
objectif du jour au lendemain de
traverser la Titicaca j'y suis allé
progressivement pour me rassurer pour me
prouver que j'en ai des capacités et
puis bah il croit très très fort il faut
toujours mettre un pied devant l'un
devant l'autre
ils ont fait mal c'est pas grave